What I want to do in this
video is talk a little bit
about quasars.
And that's a short form for
quasi-stellar radio sources.
And this name is
just a byproduct
of the first
observations of quasars.
Because all they
looked like were
these kind of point-like sources
of electromagnetic radiation,
mainly in the radio
part of the spectrum.
So that's why we called them
quasi-stellar radio sources.
Now, it turns out that they
are neither stars, or even
quasi-stellar.
And actually, their
main energy isn't even
being released in
the radio band of
the electromagnetic spectrum.
They're far more
energetic than that.
What they really are are the
active nucleuses of galaxies.
So let's think about
that a little bit.
So if we have a
supermassive black hole
at the center of
a galaxy-- so let
me draw that right over here.
So that's our
supermassive black hole.
And maybe that's the
surface of the event horizon
of the supermassive black hole.
The actual mass
of the black hole
is in the center of
that event horizon.
If there is material that's
passing by this black hole,
it's going to get
attracted to it.
And it's going to form an
accretion disk around it.
This material is going
to start rotating
around this black hole.
And some of it, if it
doesn't have enough velocity,
is going to actually
fall into the black hole.
So you have all of this material
going around the black hole.
And some of it, if it doesn't
have enough angular velocity
and not enough to orbit
around the black hole,
it's actually going to fall in.
Let me label this.
This is the accretion disk.
So as things are getting faster
and faster as they fall closer
and closer to this
black hole, and bumping
into each other more and more,
that gravitational potential
energy from things
falling into it
is being turned into actual
energy, actual temperature.
And so what you
have is things start
to get really, unbelievably
hot near the surface.
They get hotter and hotter as
they fall closer and closer
to that event horizon.
And so near the
event horizon itself,
things are so intense
that they're actually
releasing high-frequency
electromagnetic radiation,
mainly in the X-ray
part of the spectrum.
Now, I want to been very clear.
So there's two things here.
One is when you
learn about quasars,
or when I first was exposed to
quasars in like a Nova special,
they make you think that the
quasar, that the radiation is
somehow being released
by the black hole itself.
And I would scratch my
head because I was just
told that nothing can escape the
event horizon of a black hole,
including electromagnetic
radiation.
So how could that be being
emitted by the black hole?
And the answer
is, it's not being
emitted by the black hole.
It's being emitted by the matter
in the accretion disk that
hasn't quite gotten to
the event horizon yet.
Once it's inside of
the event horizon,
any electromagnetic
radiation that it might emit
will not be able to escape
the black hole anymore,
the actual event horizon.
So all of this is from
the accretion disc
around the supermassive
black hole.
And the other question
that used to pop in my mind
is why does it come out at
these kind of perpendicular,
orthogonal to the plane of
the actual accretion disk?
And at least my logic
tells me, well, things
aren't going to pop
out-- they're not
going to pop out along the
direction of the accretion disk
because then they're going to
be absorbed by other things.
In fact, that's what's going
to cause other things to get
heated up closer to the
actual event horizon.
So any energy that's going
out in that direction
is just going to be absorbed
and make other things hotter.
And only when you go roughly
perpendicular to the plane
of the accretion
disk is that energy
allowed to kind of go and
transmit freely into space.
Now, I want to be very clear.
Quasars, these are the
most luminous things
that we know of in the universe.
The brightest-- or
actually, many quasars
are on the order of a
trillion suns in luminosity.
So they can be brighter
than an entire galaxy.
And that's just
coming from material
around a fairly small
region of space,
much, much, much smaller
than an actual galaxy.
It's the very center.
It's kind of just
the galactic core.
Now another interesting
thing about quasars,
and this kind of gives
credence to this notion
of a constantly
changing universe,
and even to some degree
the Big Bang itself,
is you have these
supermassive black holes that
may be formed shortly
after the Big Bang.
Now you can imagine, at an
early stage in the universe's
development there would
have been a lot of mass that
would have been near these black
holes, that didn't have quite
the velocities to be
able to escape them or be
able to orbit around them.
And so these would
actually start
falling into the black hole.
And then over time,
all of the mass that
had to fall into the black hole,
into the supermassive black
hole, will have fallen into
the supermassive black hole.
And if you imagine at some
future period of time,
you should still have the
supermassive black hole.
But all you should see is mostly
things orbiting around it.
Anything that had
to fall into it,
would have already
fallen into it.
So you're just going to see
things orbiting around it.
And this is actually what
we see if we look around us.
If we look at our
Milky Way Galaxy,
we don't observe a lot
of things falling in.
For example, the
Milky Way Galaxy
does not have an active
nucleus, an active core.
It is not currently a quasar,
the center of the Milky Way
Galaxy.
The supermassive black
hole there is not,
I guess we could say, digesting,
is not digesting or consuming
material.
But you could imagine at some
point in the Milky Way's past,
there might have been
a lot of material
that didn't have quite the
velocity to be able to orbit.
And so that was consumed.
And as it was consumed, it
would emit all of this X-ray
radiation and could be
observed as a quasar.
And that's actually
what we observe.
The closest quasars--
and we've observed
more than 200,000 quasars--
the closest quasars are
on the order of 780
million light years away.
So what does that mean?
We don't observe quasars closer
than 700 million light years.
So what that tells
us is, at least
in our region of the universe,
the most recent quasars
were 780 million
years in the past.
When we look at closer parts
of the universe-- let me draw,
let's say this is the
observable universe.
This is us.
So we only start
to observe quasars
at a certain distance
away from us.
And that distance
is actually also
a certain time in the past.
Because it took the light 780
million years to get to us.
And actually, most
of the quasars
are more than 3 billion
light years away.
Which tells us that they
only existed more than 3
billion years in the
past, at a younger
stage of the actual
universe, when there
was actual material for these
supermassive black holes
to consume at the
center of galaxies.
You move closer in time to
us, and most of that material
has actually been consumed.
And we just have
material orbiting
around these supermassive black
holes, which we call galaxies.
And so we don't observe
quasars anymore.
And just to give an idea.
I mean these are, as everything
we learn in cosmology,
kind of these
mind-bending concepts,
unbelievable distances,
unbelievable masses,
unbelievable brightnesses, I
guess you could think about it.
But just to give a sense,
the brightest quasars,
the brightest known
quasars, devour
on the order of 1,000
solar masses per year.
So that's on the order of 10
Earths, 10 Earths per second,
if I did my math right.
10 Earths per second
are being devoured
by the brightest quasars.
And it's that energy of that
mass that's acreting around it
that's generating
all of that energy.
And actually, I should
say-- I shouldn't even
talk about it in
the present tense.
This happened in the past.
We're just observing it now.
For all we know, the
rest of the universe
looks fairly similar to
the way our universe does.
And so there really aren't
that many quasars around.
Although the other side
of the coin might be,
even though most of the
material has already
been consumed, maybe even by
our own supermassive black hole
in the center of the Milky Way,
at some point in the future,
maybe it will be able to consume
on some more stellar material,
some more-- well, any type
of material in the future.
And that might happen
about 4 or 5 billion years
in the future when we actually
collide with the Andromeda
Galaxy.
So anyway, hopefully that gave
you some food for thought.